we're going to start with some breaking
news two trains have collided in
southern pakistan's
sindh province killing more than 30
people according to local police
it appears an intercity passenger train
derailed and was hit by an
oncoming express service injured
passengers are being taken to nearby
hospitals
it's not yet clear what caused the
development and the subsequent
collision kamal haider is joining me now
from islamabad obviously we're in the
early stages
of uh this incident come up but what
else do we know
what we know so far is that this
particular
accident took place over 500 kilometers
from the city of karachi
in gothic district one train which was
northbound the other southbound collided
after one of the trains had a derailment
some of the bogies were lying
to the on the adjacent track when the
southbound train hit that with full
impact
according to reports 30 people are
confirmed dead that
that is according to the senior
superintendent of police in the area
rescue efforts were hampered and are
still being hampered because heavy
machinery is needed
to cut through the metal to get to those
people who may have survived
this terrible accident locals were the
first to respond there are
paramilitary forces at the site
however the heavy equipment has not
arrived and this is indeed a terrible
accident on a stretch of railroad
which is obsolete and there have been
other accidents on the same track
in the past as well come on just as
you've been talking to us we've been
looking at some of the pictures from the
scene
and we can see at least one of the
passenger carriages overturned possibly
one of the other carriages as well from
the other train unfortunately this is a
situation that we do
regularly report on at al jazeera just
talk us through
the safety record of pakistan's railways
well first of all it should be
remembered that most of pakistan and
india's railway system were set up by
the british
there was a modernization in the late
50s early 60s
but since then the railways has been hit
by rampant corruption
mismanagement and that of course has led
to an aging
obsolete system which should have been
basically
out of the system by now however despite
promises
of a new revamped railway line which
pakistan is negotiating with china
that plan of course has been hit by
financial constraints but the country
needs to do
a lot more in order to make railways
safer because this is
a mass transit a transport system
which caters mostly to the poor kamal
thanks very much indeed that's kamal
haider
bringing us up to date from islamabad